is frustrated as she leaves zimbabwe's
largest public hospital she says she's
been sick for months and still doesn't
know what's wrong with her
i was told i can't get blood tests done
because the labs are not working i now
have to go to a private laboratory but
they're too expensive so i haven't got
any help yet
public health workers here often
complain about low wages the lack of
personal protective equipment shortages
of drugs and medical equipment as well
as poor working conditions in some of
the medical awards you can have two
nurses nursing 40 patients in 30
patients which is which is not the
correct
patient patient ratio and this will lead
to burnout
of the nurses so the nurses that are in
the hospital right now they they are
tired uh they've got their pain out and
they
they they wish also to leave in the what
is going to happen tomorrow as far as
our health delivery system is concerned
the government's health service board
says last year more than 2 000 health
professionals left zimbabwe to take jobs
in the uk ireland australia and the us
that's more than double the number of
doctors nurses and pharmacists who left
in 2020 and three times the number of
resignations in 2019. zimbabwe's
government says it costs 70 000 a year
to train just one doctor and it takes
years before they qualify as developing
countries we are spending a lot of
scarce resources here we call them
scarce resources in training our health
workers and only to lose them to
developed countries
and so it is very ideal if such support
could be given in terms of
monetary investment or material
resources
the covert 19 pandemic has made wealthy
nations intensify recruitment and relax
visa restrictions for health workers
from poorer nations
an average worker in the public sector
takes home less than 200 a month in the
uk for example they can earn 10 times as
much despite repeated promises from the
government to improve salaries they
remain low the continued loss of trained
health professionals is worsening
zimbabwe's already overstretched public
health system and right now there seems
to be little incentive to make staff
stay hara mutasa al jazeera